mass mandate rolling out all across the
state and a shift in trends and
hospitalizations as well
these were just some of the topics
during today's discussion with health
officials
christian casadas joining us now live
from our newsroom to catch us
up well denise with covet cases on the
rise health officials say the
the state will follow cdc guidelines
that will force
new mass mandates to help minimize the
spread of the virus now during today's
covet call with
local and health state officials they
remind the public that as the virus
evolves public response
needs to change as well they stress that
vaccines are helping reduce the number
of positive cases
within the communities and added that
unvaccinated folks account for
all hospitalizations causing a burden on
local hospitals
they say vaccinations have moved from
early stages to small efforts
to reach deep into the community however
they reported a shifting trend
on those who are getting sick younger
people are being
vaccinated excuse me are being
hospitalized
uh partly because they're not getting
vaccinated at the same rates
uh and so they're the people getting
sick right now so that's where we're
seeing that
that boost there the positive news is
that those folks
tend to get less severe versions of the
disease well health officials added that
younger people in general are recovering
fast
and are being discharged from the
hospitals faster also
treatment for the virus has improved but
best way they say to stay
out of the hospitals is to get
vaccinated now remember if
you get the virus symptoms don't begin
to show until four
to seven days later again they want the
public to wear one of these
one of your like one of your masks
whether you know it's you know the
disposable ones or these cloth ones
in large gatherings vaccinated or not
especially with the delta variant
christian gossip is 8 news now